here's a story from the daily mails from
several days ago that somehow we haven't
talked about yet and i want to mention
it because of course it's very relevant
to the news this week
it says pediatricians across america
are at war with their own professional
body over controversial puberty blocking
drugs routinely handed to teens wanting
to change gender the top child health
experts
accused the american academy of
pediatrics of pushing the harmful drugs
on transgender identifying youngsters
according to damning leaked documents
disturbingly the documents also reveal
experts believe that the a the app
um
or that's actually the aap is
deliberately silencing internal
criticism by blocking moves for a
crucial policy review
the papers leaked by a whistleblower
exposed how rank and file aap members
across the u.s are slamming the
academy's shoddy drugs and hormones
first approach to trans-identifying
teens
they insist
that many would benefit from counseling
or therapy instead oh you think
and urge the professional body to follow
a more cautious approach currently being
adopted by similar bodies in other
countries
fast-tracking adolescents into powerful
drug cocktails takes a huge toll on
young bodies and can lead to sterility
and osteoporosis osteoporosis according
to critics for many teams transitioning
is celebrated but others regret the
treatment and seek reversals
the aap for its part says that its
guidelines to reinforce the gender of
youth selects including through drugs
cross-sex hormones and eventually
surgery are evidence-based and that it's
open to collaborative conversations on
policy
but angry aap members say the academy
changed its rules to block a member
drafted resolution to launch a policy
review
and by the way just a side note here
the ap says that its guidelines are
evidence-based
that's completely false there's really
no evidence to support any of this stuff
and that actually was in
you know i kind of whittled down the the
clip that we played of dr montano that
we played at the start of the show
um that's like i said it's a 20-minute
interview and it's worth going to
youtube until it's taken down until they
delete it it's probably already deleted
but if you can watch the whole thing you
should do that uh because there's
another interesting point in that
interview
when he's asked about
sort of the like long-term studies um
related to
you know giving kids these kinds of
drugs puberty blockers and then
comparing that to kids who have gender
dysphoria but are not given the drugs
and like long term if you compare the
two groups uh what do the studies say
and he admits in the interview that well
there aren't any studies
we don't have any studies on that
which of course we don't because we've
never been doing this to kids before
certainly not on this scale or anything
close to this scale
so no there's no evidence there there
are no long-term studies to to to
validate or vindicate or
most of the things that we're doing here
or any of them
so evidence-based is a total lie
now the reason why the aap the american
academy of pediatrics
has adopted this approach and endorsed
it
the reason why it's all politics it's
all ideology all the way down
they are told by wpath
which is the big transgender health
association in the world and wpath just
tells everyone what the uh guidelines
are for dealing with trans kids and then
all of the other medical institutions
and organizations dutifully follow suit
without questioning it without asking
any questions or anything
and as we see here from these
whistleblowers if anyone within the
organizations does ask questions or
raise concerns or raise any red flags
they're silenced
as daily mail says angry aap members say
the academy changed its rules to block a
member-drafted resolution to launch a
policy review it led to the
review being sidelined at the academy's
leadership conference which ended in
chicago on monday
instead members took the unusual step of
airing their concerns in the comments
section for a separate resolution in the
aap's member only website in the
comments leaked to dailymail.com aap
members said the academy was endorsing
great harm
that its care package for
trans-identified teens was based on
scant and shoddy evidence
and that doling out drugs and hormones
was unsafe and unsustainable
one pediatrician wrote before
promulgating gender affirming care with
all of its ethical complications
irreversible body bodily changes
sterility etc don't we want to be sure
that this is the best path
another member said that there was no
good long-term outcome data for those
who undergo the arduous physical process
of transitioning
and pointed to the 37 000 members of an
online forum for regretful d
transitioners as they are known you know
our friends over at goodranchers are on
a mission to donate 100 000 high quality
meals this month to children in need you
can help them reach their goal by
ordering your next box at
goodranchers.com
for every box ordered through august
31st goodranchers will donate a
nutritious meal to a child in need you
can help these guys reach their goal and
get 30 off plus free shipping at
goodranchers.com
matt
now
it's good that these uh
um
[Music]
whistleblowers are coming out and and
criticizing
but it's not nearly enough
okay to do it anonymously is not nearly
enough
and i and i understand
you know if you're a pediatrician and
you come out against the aap publicly
and you do so on the trans stuff
uh
you know you're putting your career on
the line
career you've worked hard for
spend a lot of time in school spend a
lot of money on the student loans
to put that on the line that that takes
uh it takes a lot of courage
there's no understating the amount of
courage it takes to put your entire
career on the line but that is what's
required
okay so if you're a pediatrician and i
hear from pediatricians all the time
actually
again never wanting to go on the record
but they'll message me privately and say
hey i agree with everything you say on
this stuff keep saying it
so i know that there are some listening
to me right now and what i want to say
to you
is that it is not good enough
to be anonymous you have a
responsibility to speak up publicly and
put your name on it
and if you want to do that and you want
a platform if you're if you're ready and
willing to come out publicly and speak
out against this stuff especially if
you're a member of the a the american
academy pediatrics
and you're ready to do the right thing
with your name on it
then reach out to me
i'll make sure that your concerns are
hurt
because when you voice them anonymously
on message boards and in comment
sections
and you send private emails to
conservative podcasters
that doesn't do anything
i mean you're the first line of defense
you're the people that we need
because i can i can sit here all day and
forever which i will speaking out
against this stuff
but what i'm always going to run into is
the claim oh you're not a doctor you're
not an expert
which of course is irrelevant you don't
need to be a doctor or an expert to know
that you shouldn't mutilate and chill
and castrate children all you need is
common sense and a soul
which is something sorely lacking on the
left
which explains how we got here
but whether it should or not the the
expertise and all that it it it does
matter to people
so it would be a lot more powerful i
mean there should be
press conferences
with whole groups of pediatricians
speaking out against this answering
questions
explaining their position
talking about what's going on behind the
scenes
[Music]
and until that happens this isn't going
to get any better
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast